un homme inconscient entouré par les
secours et les rues adjacentes à la plus
belle avenue du monde recouverte d'un
nuage de gaz lacrymogène alors que la
police repousse les derniers
manifestants
des images qui témoignent d'une fin de
soirée sous tension et à la proche de la
présidentielle de tout ce que le
gouvernement espérait ne pas voir après
le rassemblement d'opposants au pass
vaccinale plus tôt dans la journée ils
étaient des milliers à s'être retrouvés
aux portes de paris avec un objectif
rejoindre les champs elysées afin
d'éviter un blocage de la capitale sept
mille deux cents policiers et gendarmes
ont été mobilisés
soutenu par plusieurs blindés pourtant
malgré cet important dispositif et
l'interdiction de manifester annoncée
par la préfecture de paris le convoi de
la liberté réussi en début d'après-midi
atteindre l'arc de triomphe
les mondiale la victoire c'est pas que
nous chasser c'est global contre les
élites et contre l'indifférence contre
la gauche toute la malveillance et c'est
des gens qui se soulèvent pour justement
montrer leur amour interne et à l'oral
mort intérieur et se battre encore
jusqu'au bout il ya eu quelque chose
d'extraordinaire sur la route je le dis
vraiment en klaxonnant partout où il est
passé par les nationales les gens nous
ont fait des signes on a même vu un
maire avec avec son écharpe me faire des
consignes et où une ambiance de folie et
à tous les points de chute des bénévoles
qui étaient là avec des victuailles et
où c'était vraiment quelque chose assez
extraordinaire afin de disperser les
manifestants et de libérer les
champs-elysées les forces de l'ordre
font usage de gaz lacrymogènes
en marge de la manifestation jérôme
rodriguez figure d gilet jaune et
soutient des convois anti mesures
sanitaires est interpellé pour avoir
organisé une manifestation interdite par
le préfet de police de paris un jour -
rodez ne sait jamais en fait le
revendiquer comme un organisateur convoi
de la liberté il a dit qu'il soutenait
en fait ce convoi de la liberté mais
rendez vous compte que tu étais par la
rue saint-honoré c'était trois personnes
dont il n'est pas dit dans le mouvement
en fait du congo la liberté ils étaient
juste là pour la levée ce qui les
contactent manceau noir
en début de soirée la situation reste
tendue et la police peine à évacuer les
manifestants de plus en plus nombreux
bilan 54 interpellations et plus de 300
verbalisation ce dimanche le convoi va
prendre la direction de bruxelles où des
convois de toute l'europe ont prévu de
se retrouver